hey guys we're doing another Q&A you
guys submitted questions on Ora TV and
on the Twitter so here we go
James Leigh asked how likely do you
think that Bernie Sanders will be the
next president if you guys know anything
about me at this point you know that I
do like Bernie he's the guy that I
pretty much everything he says I pretty
much agree with I don't know that we
could pay for all of it but I'm pretty
much there like Bernie I have a hard
time making fun of him except for the
Larry David stuff where Jess and I was
handling pretty well
how likely unfortunately I find it very
hard to believe that sort of an old
socialist from from New Hampshire is
gonna be the next president I don't
necessarily see it but don't lose hope
people get angry every time I say that
that doesn't mean that this thing is not
good because what he can do is look if
it's gonna be Hillary on the Democratic
side he can push her left or pull her
left right and what he can also do
beyond that is change the dialogue even
after whoever even if a Republican
became the next president you know some
of the social stuff and the money in
politics and the 1% all that stuff he's
made that discussion important and not
everything always comes just because the
president's the guy in charge so try to
feel good about that at Ken cotton the
third asked where do you draw the line
between feeling bad for mislead college
kids raised to drink regressive kool-aid
and holding them accountable for their
actions and ideas as young adults you
know look I think that we have to call
them out on this because if we don't
we're just actually making their safe
space that much safer right we can't
issue trigger warnings to everyone that
is upset by everything so we have to
call them out and the funny thing is I'm
not that old but it does when I talk
about it I do feel kind of old but you
know what everyone's realizing this you
can see even in the media in general
which agrees on nothing right you can
see that people have just had enough of
this stuff we have to protect free
speech more than anything else at Jordy
Aquino said this is more apparent in
Europe how is the liberal left turned
its back on the Jewish communities that
are seeing the rise of anti-semitism why
are so few liberals speaking out on this
rising problem you know this is
particularly interesting when I was in
Israel a couple weeks ago one of the
most disturbing things that I saw
that many of the realtors that have
signs outside that are you know renting
apartments or selling houses or whatever
they were in Hebrew and in French tons
of them in French so yeah the people of
France are they're starting to deal with
this and some people are actually
leaving I don't know why this makes no
sense to me this issue with the left I
think in a weird way the left always
wants to protect the other but doesn't
consider Jews the other anymore
something like that I don't know it's
it's it's actually pretty depressing and
disturbing at Stephen Jay G Hubbard how
do you think atheists are doing at
creating traditions events ceremonies
groups etc to replicate the positive
social value that religious
congregations produce for theists I
don't know many examples of that I think
this is an interesting point because
even people that don't like religion
right understand that there are some
good things about religion a sense of
community and where you can meet people
like-minded people and all that I don't
know that many instances where people
have come together in the name of
atheism but we sort of have seen it on
social media right that's why a lot of
you guys are watching this so that's
nice but there are things like the
reason rally which I think I'm speaking
at in a couple months and a whole bunch
of other there are events that people
get together but in terms of you know
traditions and things like that it's a
little bit out of the atheist sort of
pocket but if people can come together
on secular values I think that's good
enough Josh
Voytek how do we get those so heavily
entrenched on the regressive left to
start working with us towards true
liberalism how do we encourage people
who might have changed their mind from a
regressive ill liberal position to admit
that they were wrong and start talking
about the true dangers of bad ideologies
I wish I had the answer to this one I
think all we can keep doing is is keep
talking about it right all we can do is
present our side of the argument now
ironically this is what they hate the
most and that's why if you say something
but they don't like you're a bigot and
racist and a homophobe into sexist and
all that other nonsense but I would say
that if you're not a bigot and a
homophobe and a racist and a sexist then
don't be afraid of saying your opinions
if someone was to call me racist while I
know that I'm not racist so I don't like
to be called it it's not nice I would
prefer not to be called it but at the
end of the day I'm not I'm not a
homophobe but I'm not
not against women and I'm for equality
and I'm trying to help out the other and
and I'm trying to be better myself and
that's I think all you can do
Jackie Lu said would you ever consider
hosting a debate with two guests on
Rubin report so I definitely do want to
do more this one of the shows that we've
done I had a panel I used to do more
panel stuff in general I would get I
would like to get people on here for a
little more back and forth I think part
of the issue is that I think you guys
have really liked and I've really liked
having one-on-one focused long-form
conversations because there's so little
of it and I don't really want to just
talk to two people you know get a
Democratic operative and a Republican
operative and have them spout off
talking points but if you guys can think
of some people that you would like to
hear sort of go at it and I can kind of
moderate it I'm totally down to do that
so let me know at Pascale laro have you
heard about Canada's push to legalize
pot how do you feel about that I didn't
know about that but I feel good about it
yeah pot should be legal right people
aren't smoking pot and and murdering
people people aren't smoking pot and and
you know breaking into banks we should
be legal there's a lot of medicinal
reasons which we all know and even
beyond the medicinal reasons even if
there were no medicinal reasons if you
want to smoke a joint at the end of the
day and watch The Simpsons
maybe hinting off to what I do yeah
there's nothing wrong with that and if
you want to smoke pot early in the
morning and take a walk in the park
nothing wrong with that either Joe said
I would love to hear your view on US
economics I like most of your viewers
I'm socially liberal but I'm also
fiscally conservative any chance to get
a libertarian on the show so I would
love to have a libertarian on the show I
consider myself partly libertarian I've
defended Rand Paul in a lot of unpopular
places before I do think that basically
the government should be pretty much out
of your life and ironically if the
libertarians ever held themselves to
libertarian values I think it would do
better for them so libertarian if you're
a libertarian you shouldn't care what
someone smokes like marijuana and you
shouldn't care what someone does in
their bedroom a gay couple for example
so if they would live up to their own
values I think it would do them a world
of good but I do think that there are a
lot of
a lot of common ground between liberals
and libertarians and I hope they can
come together and finally Mikaela am
best episode or Sima in the Golden Girls
this one is tough this was the hardest
of all questions but my favorite episode
of The Golden Girls is when clayton's
when Blanche's brother Clayton he's gay
he comes out in an earlier episode and
it's a second episode now he's marrying
Doug this cop and the two guys you know
they're in there probably I don't know
late 40s early 50s or so they're
completely there doesn't seem to be
anything gay about them other than they
are gay right and that's sort of how
I've always felt and there's a there's a
scene where Blanche realizes that her
brother is gonna marry this guy now it's
interesting this was I think in 1990 or
1991 on NBC at 9 o'clock at night and
they never even mentioned that gay
marriage wasn't legal like they were
just like oh they're getting gay married
it was just a thing that shows you how
truly progressive not regressive the
show was and there were many other
instances of this kind of thing but
anyway Blanche is saying well why do you
wanna why do you want to marry Doug
she's asking Clayton and Clayton says
well I'd do anything for Doug and he'd
bend over backwards for me and that is a
gay anal sex joke that they did on the
Golden Girls at 9:00 p.m. in around 1990
on NBC primetime television that's how
brilliant the show was because they were
dealing with a real issue making it
wickedly funny and also like kind of
subversive so that would be my favorite
Golden Girls anyway thank you guys for
playing along you can always use hashtag
ask Dave Rubin on Twitter and you can go
to or at itv and fill out the form right
there so thank you